[Musique]
les skieurs sont de retour sur les
pentes ce n'est pas encore la foule mais
cet hiver ils seront nombreux ouais
c'est la première fois l'état d'esprit
de commencer le
temps
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le ski alpin connaît un nouvel essor au
Québec depuis quelques années et la
covit semble avoir accélérer c'est
tendance
de profiter de la vie plus de peux
rester à la maison tout le temps surtout
retraités faut s'occuper
dans le 74 station de ski du Québec
une
des abonnements tous les
mêmes choses
gros saison en vu aussi au mont
Saint-Bruno la station la plus
rapprochée de Montréal
et
environ 50 pour ça que c'est des
nouvelles personnes qui était jamais
venu à la montagne donc pour nous c'est
un grand succès ski Saint-Bruno qui est
la plus importante école de ski alpin
pour la première fois de ne plus offrir
de cours les après-midi de fin de
semaine question de faire plus de place
au ski à Hordain jours obligé de
réserver m'avoir conseillé fortement
nous si on voit pas sur tous les soirs
ça envoie quel âge est assez élevé le
nombre de billets donc on va contrôler
au niveau des soirées au niveau des
journalistes il y a les gens c'est très
important de réserver à l'avance
vraiment acheter à l'avance pour
s'assurer disponible pour l'instant de
construire une belle expérience en
station au Mont-Tremblant ou la surface
skiable est beaucoup plus grande on ne
compte pas limiter les entrées cet hiver
même chose à Bromont en Estrie mais une
majorité de stations pourrait bien le
faire surtout pendant les vacances
parce que la pandémie n'ai pas encore
fini d'ailleurs le passeport vaccinal
est obligatoire partout cet hiver chaque
skieur sera contrôler à l'entrée les
mesures sont beaucoup des
recommandations de mon niveau des
télésièges les gens le vrai visage
recommandé il y a plus de restriction à
l'extérieur ce qui s'est passé le fait
que l'ensemble des service à la
clientèle peuvent être ouvert en
ligne
est-ce que les
questions de prévoir
[Musique]
parce qu'elle en a besoin de vos
lumières heureusement qu'en fait de la
neige oui
est-ce que ça va aller c'est un épisode
de pluie
[Musique]
si on est jumelle malgré tout on a quand
même tendance
Noël vers
son verre
c'est qui envoie aussi dans les parages
action sur
une association qui a fait une étude des
chèvres
s'il y avait pas eu donc cette invention
avec c'est compliqué faire de la neige
avec de l'eau
mets-moi sur le ski de fond la raquette
parce qu'on peut pas faire de la neige
la semaine prochaine on va se voir la
fin de l'émission